working with max yeah what was that like
for you max is such an incredible
director and you can see it's in his
blood
obviously he worked on this film for 12
years of his life this is kind of it was
just so amazing seeing him and he
doesn't feel like a first-time director
he was so planned out in his mind and
you can see this and he also he's a very
it's like a pop is he really yes he
loves pop music how many time that you
like that yeah you can say I didn't
think he would say it about himself
probably but it's like he loves pop
music like he's really obsessed with
that world so yeah well we saw lots of
photos of you guys before we knew you
were working together
yeah was it weird to hear about all that
like dating speculation I do you know I
mean we just really love working
together Elle Fanning and addressing
those max Minghella romance rumors and
that was like very special and he's such
a good friend you know that I I'll do
any other movie that he wants me to do
so his second whatever yeah max makes
his directorial debut with teen spirit
while L stars in the flake
what made el the perfect actress to
really carry this I think she's the only
actress you could have carried it and I
mean that's not being hyperbolic it's
it's it's an incredible list of
requirements you have to be able to sing
you've got to be able to dance you've
got to be able to you know speak polish
basically do the British accent play the
age range and carry a movie with an
incredibly nuanced performance and she
just handled everything with such kind
of discipline and professionalism and
she did all of her singing live it's
amazing it's an amazing piece of work
[Music]
it's funny I was just talking to Ellen
she called you a pop I love pop music I
listen to dancing on my own when right
when it came out that rolling song I
love that song the movie now when I see
the poem it all feels like it has a very
specific Hahnemann that comes out of
that yeah
I've been introduced to so many pop
artists through max I've been over it so
something like what are you listening
really like to offer violins
al plays viola it's a Polish student who
enters a singing competition show he's
not a real manager
or anything but yeah so not for me the
actress trained with several vocal
coaches and choreographers for three
months there's a lot of people like
involved to get me the noise I danced
growing up I did a lot of ballet and I
love to dance but just showing having
that in a film and was something very
new to me
you were in an experience before it was
a Polish name talked about learning to
speak polish yeah it was it difficult
yes I am you know it's polish is also
not a language that I hear every day so
I think when it's something that's
completely just well like there's just
completely new to me and also I he you
know would do it phonetically so I would
be just kind of the sounds of it making
sure that each line is it's properly
do you want to pursue a singing career
you know I would you know I actually
would I who knows like not Oh career I
don't know how I would never I'm still
yeah act and would love to I mean
obviously still act and that's my my
thing but it's cool like it opened the
door to that and I would never say no to
maybe you know who knows yeah I don't
know I really enjoyed it like I really
enjoyed it
[Music]